hello there reject nation ungrate other
I'm we're gonna watch 31 moments for a
family guy that will always be funny
this was uploaded from the YouTube
channel next-of-kin let's see if these
moments are always funny
are you ready Amy I am ready let's see
if they make me ha ha see that made me
ha ha ha ha ha Blackey weather forecast
[Music]
[Music]
no your first responsibility is to fire
that employee I hope no one notices Oh
what's going on even know what a
minstrel cycle is yeah stadion Weinstock
and Riesman handle run down now I got
four people on hold but I can't talk are
you kidding
god this is worse than having Ronald
McDonald for father
[Music]
my god I'm a tomato tell women have
always treated me pieces my name isn't
Adam we or is it
Who am I what number did you die don't
ever call here again I guess I told him
nobody messes with sessions presents a
Peter Griffin Christmas feature oh yeah
and who could forget I brought these
gifts for you my bum and everyone's
favorite get the best holy crap here
comes Jesus and he doesn't look too
happy
Merry Christmas everyone yo man hey Jase
hey I've just been checking out some of
that internet porn you okay go and check
my mail over there
[Laughter]
yeah if you're looking for a bad time
that's what you're after you want it bad
you don't care who you get it from
because you have been super Specter that
gets you off I don't know Brian maybe
Lois is right maybe it's time for me to
get a job yeah too bad you always blow
it in the interview so Peter where do
you see yourself in five years
don't say doing your wife don't see
doing your wife don't say doing your
wife doing you son yes sir it was a good
day but young Peter
[Music]
you mean cool cool cool you're saying it
weird why are you putting so much
emphasis on the H cool badass back here
oh that's good oh gee
like the end of a Tarantino film rights
for all except blacks Asians Hispanics
Jews gays women Muslims everybody who's
not a white man and I mean white one so
no Italians just full-blooded whites you
know what
not even ways nobody gets any rice
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's great that's great
reverend comedy revered crude humor i
remembered most of those I didn't
remember I I remember like I've seen
this one but I didn't remember like a
lot of the jokes yeah but it's still so
great or a lot I actually hadn't seen a
man it's really cool whip whip one cool
whip one cool whip what what way like
yeah there's only like a two or three I
remember by heart
I love the Ronald McDonald one message
to me when I was at Comic Con I went to
the panel for Seth MacFarlane's the
Orval he did like three panels
back-to-back for Family Guy American Dad
than Orville and I managed to get a new
Corvo I've never seen the Orville I mean
I suppose he's at the far left cuz he
was amazing he was so hysterical I'm
like the way he interacts with crowds
and audience members and stuff he's such
a hard-working talent you know he's got
so many things in production at once his
voice talent and his comedic skills or
brilliant he can sing hey how much going
on that man doing his humor I feel like
sometimes we underestimate or overlook
just how much of a talent that guy is
also just cuz he's been doing it for so
long too so we just get used to it's
like a Family Guy it's always there yeah
but it's so good and what you're able to
get away with jokes and comedy that you
wouldn't necessarily be able to get away
with it in person so you can like push
those boundaries more I think Family Guy
is one of the greatest shows of all time
because it was canceled after three seas
a lot people forget that it was canceled
it was like it was on fault it was done
it was on Fox News canceled and then it
started like having a good repeat value
on reruns on I don't think on Fox on a
different network but they never sell is
at the time before streaming so there
was a lot of DVDs that were then people
were buying the DVDs so it had all these
sales they were like maybe we should
bring this back it was off he was like
done for a while and then suddenly it
comes back with a season four and it's
this juggernaut cultural hit I feel like
that also gets taken for granted as well
just how much of an impact the show has
had yeah especially considering that it
didn't come on the scene it was like yep
the landmark show it took some time for
people who really took a few hits and
then suddenly after that I got Family
Guy American Dad and a whole bunch of
other Seth MacFarlane goodies and
everything it's still funny it still it
is I haven't seen the last couple
seasons but whenever I put it back on
there's something very seal good about
it for me I can put it on okay I know
I'm gonna laugh despite all the violence
and Ruby happening there's something
that's just gonna like hit that spot for
you and you're like oh yeah it's one of
those shows that I always feel is met
with like the stupid controversy like oh
family guys pissed off this part of the
world or is pissed off this group of
people that it's comedy
I love it I mean there are times I watch
it and I go oh that's for you edgy and
dark but I'm always like well someone
else might not be pretty
yeah that's the thing it's subjective
there are things that I might find very
offensive but other people won't
likewise there are gonna things that
people find very offensive that I'm
gonna be like yeah I don't care about
that you know it's comedy
yes it's competent person I'll take it
seriously and they're supposed to push
the boundaries and man do they push the
boundaries a lot that they do and I also
think the show is cool their ability to
commit to like violent physical bits I
think is really impressive like the
whole thing with the ongoing bit with
Peter fighting that chicken is so funny
and like cool too it's like also awesome
to watch that fight go down sometimes
they have these action scenes in here
like that's not funny
but that's awesome yes I treasured this
ship
there's something for everyone unless
you just get extremely offended and
that's not the show for you but for
everybody else yeah okay if you're
priest I wouldn't watch it no that's
what that's the moral of this story
you're creased don't watch everybody
other foods well I try watching it with
my priest he did not laugh no did he
pray mm-hmm okay and touch me oh okay
that's maybe just I might have been a
bad priest i watch this channel alright
guys well thanks for watching subscribe
to the real rejects check out Amy
castles channel it's Amy castle please
do as soon as you can't follow our
instagram and such well catch you guys
soon but hey let's give a page of the
day shout to someone I like to give a
patient the day shot to a lovely lady
named Victoria Huntley Victoria was
telling me she was a pretty big
following right now cuz just cosplaying
and she lives in in the UK and she told
me something interesting she said that
uh because she has a priest because she
has social she can have some social
anxiety from time to time and she says
cosplaying actually really helps her
with social anxiety I never viewed it
like that I always thought cosplayers
were a bunch of idiots it's much a loser
I make sense though because you're
getting to be somebody else that's true
I walk around Halloween and I'm like
what's all these dumbasses - be yourself
morons it's weird how some people find
cosplaying to be an escape and a comfort
for me I feel like it would take courage
I wouldn't feel exactly comfortable
cosplaying and I feel like I'd have to
take a little bit of courage to do it
interest I don't know why but then if
you're around a bunch of people that are
all doing the same thing I would feel
like oh I'm more like everybody else by
dressing up and it would like relieve
some of my anxiety right okay I'm like
in this world now with everybody else do
the same thing and Victoria she cosplays
in like Harry Potter outfits I'm about
this
so like [ __ ] her - oh okay bloody
Hermione
[ __ ] Harry it's a really [ __ ] love
that Sarabeth's kharab [ __ ] for hot
just red pubes alright now we're done
we're done
sorry she doesn't do that Victoria is a
really sweet girl you're really sweet
girl